hello everyone I'm Alicia Malone welcome
to Fandango indie movie Guide and the
film that I really want to recommend
this week is three billboards outside
Epping Missouri put this one on the
awards watch radar hopefully for Frances
McDormand who plays a mother who is
really unhappy with the police for not
moving fast enough with her daughter's
murder case so she puts up three
billboards outside Epping Missouri still
no arrest how come I wonder cuz there
ain't no God in the whole world's empty
and you don't matter what we do to each
other this was directed by Martin
McDonagh who was the guy behind in
Bruges and Seven Psychopaths and I'm
gonna say something that might be a
little controversial I think this is his
best film he has really proven a mastery
of changing tone you will laugh one
second you'll be shocked the next and
you'll cry a minute later we've had two
official complaints about those
billboards from a who lady was a funny I
the lady with the funny fat Dennis so a
lot of good friends will be in this town
is a little did you ah concert of course
not
this film also has a lot to say about
police brutality and living in a Trump
era hopefully we'll see Francis
McDormand being nominated for Best Lead
Actor I'd also love to see Sam Rockwell
get a nod for Best Supporting Actor and
Woody Harrelson is fantastic too
definitely don't miss this wonderful
movie three billboards outside Epping
Missouri will be in theaters from this
weekend
I had some food I give it to you well I
got us some Doritos they might kill you
they're kind of pointy then where would
we be another film that I really want to
put on your radar for this weekend is
Thelma this is a fantastic indeed
Norwegian horror film by director Yocum
tria he was very much inspired by 80s
and late seventies genre films and you
can feel the influence of something like
Carrie
the story is about a young girl who
discovers as she's coming of age and
falling in love that she has these
almost supernatural tendencies it's like
she's trying to hold back who she really
is because she's ashamed of it or
doesn't want to give in to its power
great special effects beautiful
cinematography I really enjoyed the
twists and turns and surreal beauty of
Thelma you can see it out in theaters
this weekend
if you're looking for a sweet comedy to
watch in theaters or on video on demand
check out Amanda and Jack go glamping
we should go we're not staying here for
us
you're staying for Magic Mike this does
David Arquette as one half of a married
couple who go glamping that is glamorous
camping to try to rekindle their romance
but unexpectedly they're not by
themselves it's a very sweet film and
tell some truths about relationships
Amanda and Jack go glamping you guys
have totally need for glamping glamping
[Music]
and to close it out there are one two
three Indies I really want to recommend
to you that are playing now on Fandango
now the first one good time starring
Robert Pattinson
directed by these safty brothers it's a
guerilla style thriller set in New York
don't count your chickens before they
hatch do you understand that
No
then patty-cakes and inspirational rap
musical starring Daniel McDonald as a
girl who wants to be a rap star your pen
game is ridiculous
you have notebooks full size feet how
bad did you want this you don't have a
musical bone in your body you sure as
hell can't see what kind of music are we
talking about here
burn wrap and beach rats directed by
Eliza hitmen a drama about a man who's
coming to terms with his own sexuality
have you ever made out with a girl
before sure lots of times she's hot when
two girls made out the thing is how and
two guys make out
don't miss those three and just to run
you through all of them again because I
know I stir a lot at you they're in
theaters you can see three billboards
outside Epping Missouri thelma or the
comedy Amanda and Jack go glamping and
on Fandango now check out good time
patty cakes and beach wraps
I'm Alicia Malone and for my question of
the week I want to know who do you hope
gets an Oscar nomination from the movies
that you've seen thus far I'm all about
early predictions you can also follow me
on twitter at Alicia Malone I'll see you
soon bye
[Music]